we feel good where we are right now you
know like i said before we feel you know
we've done a lot of things that we can
uh give us flexibility you know through
the draft and free agency so you know
for right now we feel very good where we
are you know the narrative was out there
you know we were tanking and that was
clear was not what we were doing you
know it's important to establish that
culture of winning the importance of
winning and doing things the right way
so for us it's just to keep building
upon that and i think we had a good
start at the end of the year how we
played the second half of the season and
just gotta keep building from
there chris greer dolphins general
manager regarding the transformation of
the team during the 2019 season early on
they were tanking and their owner had
been making no bones about the fact that
you got to take some lumps in order to
lay the foundation for the future and i
think they just got to the point where
they were sick of it they didn't like
how it felt they didn't like how it was
unfolding brian flores first year head
coach took charge of the situation
remember they were going to go all in
with josh rosen for the rest of the year
and then flores basically said screw it
yeah we're better off with ryan
fitzpatrick if we want to win football
games and they did all right so the
question now becomes chris sims could
the dolphins actually take over the
patriots in
2020 in the afc east even if tom brady
stays in new england well i don't think
we're there yet i'm really fascinated
and pumped up about where the dolphins
can go i mean first off i think chris
career was very correct there in his
statement you know you want to yeah okay
you want to tank to your point but you
do want to instill some winning culture
and give people some confidence who
might sign there as free agents that
things are going in the right direction
too and i think miami did that they have
a plethora of picks there's no doubt
about that but we're still going into
the season with ryan fitzpatrick we
don't know who the quarterback of the
future is and there's a lot of
rebuilding to do there in miami i mean
they need everything i mean almost
everything and i'm not i'm not trying to
they need better offense alignment they
need better pass rushers they need help
in the secondary other than xavier
howard this is a total rebuild so i
would say we're not there yet mike okay
now for the next the rest of the decade
they're gonna be a challenger mike the
team to me that fits that mold buffalo
bills that's what i would say watch out
for
but but you get it right i mean look at
buffalo they were in the playoffs as we
know they got their quarterback rookie
contract they have a ton
a ton of cap space we talk about the
miami dolphins with their you know 90
plus million the bills are right around
80 million in cap space you have that
they are very close so yes they don't
have the plethora of picks the miami
dolphins have in the draft but like if
i'm the buffalo bills right now and i'm
mcdermott and brandon bean i'm going ooh
there's blood in the water the patriots
are not the patriots we've seen for the
last 20 years we're improving as a team
we got the qb on the rookie salary
strike now buffalo bills kill free
agency get a difference maker for josh
allen to throw to
get a difference maker pass rusher off
the edge they can really change their
team and have an opportunity here with
the end of the brady era and you know
belichick coming down the the final
stretch here to where they could take
over the afc east and have a chance to
be that dominant team here for the next
few years
the new england patriots have won the
afc east every year since
2009 they also won 2003 through 2007.
the only year they didn't win was the
year that tom brady suffered the torn
acl week one at home against the kansas
city chief bernard pauler hit him low he
was done they were 11 and five yes but
the dog the dolphins who had chad
pennington fall into their laps after
the jets got brett favre and cut
pennington the dolphins ended up winning
the division then so it's felt
inevitable
that the patriots are going to surrender
that title at some point to someone else
in the division given that they didn't
have a buy last year given they lost in
the wild card round of the playoffs
maybe that's that
sense is strengthening but i tend to
agree with you i think the bills are in
better shape yeah than the dolphins to
overtake now but the dolphins are in a
position this year with all those draft
picks if they use them and they use them
well they could lay the foundation for a
team that could be very very good years
into the future chris yeah i think
that's that's the big point there with
the dolphins that things are going in
the right direction
i as you know have great faith in brian
flores knowing him for a long long time
he's tough he's got he's very smart he's
creative he knows what it takes to build
a football team and all the little
intricacies there and of course being in
new england he's seen a lot of
high-level players to go oh okay we need
a richard seymour oh i've seen a richard
seymour before i know how to find that
guy i mean he can go down the list to
get those type of guys to where yes this
is a huge offseason for the miami
dolphins and they can really set
themselves up for yeah like i said i'm
not looking at them as a 2020 super bowl
contender but you can set them they can
set themselves up for being in that
conversation for 2021 2022 and so on if
they kill free agency the draft and all
of that and get everything going in the
right direction in miami
and one team we have not mentioned that
is also in the afc
team that who knows who they finished
seven and nine last year after starting
one and seven
six and two down the stretch are we
sleeping on the jets jets jets jets i do
i think we are sleeping on them i don't
think there's any doubt about it you
know they're another team it's they got
some things you like you know of course
got sam darnold you know the big thing
with them is they're a little bit like
we're just they need to reconstruct
their own line they need to some
difference makers on their front seven i
mean
who who who's who's the guy that like
f's the play up for the for the new york
jets who's the secondary guy at corner
you could say oh he can match up so they
have work to do you know that's really
where i didn't like people jumping on
adam gase last year
that roster was nothing to write home
about and of course then when mosley and
sam darnold getting hurt that made it
even worse so yes i think the jets are
one of those teams that's flying under
the radar very quiet right now but have
a lot of money to spend too in free
agency and can change around the dynamic
of their football team too here going
into 2020.
yeah look i i feel like the afc east is
more wide open than it's been in years
even if tom brady stays with the new
england patriots because they got a lot
of work to do they do to put the talent
around him to make the organization uh
uh what it's been and uh and i like that
i like it when hey
it's
the patriots had cracked the code on the
entire national football yes they have
and this doesn't make me anti-patriots
they've got six super bowl championships
there are plenty of teams out there that
would love to have
one so
uh yeah let somebody else have a turn
new england patriots it's not a bad
thing for there to be some parody in the
national football league i remember back
in the 70s chris pete rozelle hated the
fact that it was all steelers and
raiders and dolphins and cowboys
and this is his vision generally
speaking of what the nfl could be
but then there are the patriots screwing
everything up 2020 or 2019 rather was a
lot closer to maybe what it could be
because we saw extreme parity in the nfc
we saw week 17 come down to the wire to
determine the seating yeah we saw the
chiefs end up with a buy when they
weren't supposed to have one week 17 it
was determined that's what pete rozelle
wanted and uh if the patriots diminish
just a little bit they can still be in
the mix but if they're not dominant that
that gives us that that hope for every
team in any given year that maybe they
can be competitive maybe they can get to
the playoffs and anybody who gets to the
playoffs who knows yeah maybe you get
lucky and you can run the team you're
right and you know again as much as i
know what pete roselle wanted and all
those things too the patriots have been
good for football i mean it's good to
have that you know hate love type team
in the sport that we all want to tune in
to see like either we going to see ooh
the greatness of this dynasty or oh my
gosh i want to see them lose i can't
stand them anymore i think that's kind
of where everybody stands as far as the
the conversation with the new england
patriots this is the crazy thing about
the patriots though and this is where
you just don't know if they'll ever die
because yeah they're in a little bit of
a rebuild mode like you said there's
things they got to fill in offensive
lines not real strong right you know
defense they got some free agents there
kyle van noy jamie collins they need
some difference makers you know the
mccourty twins are getting up there in
age stephan gilmore not getting any
younger we know they need wide receivers
but the freaking crazy thing about the
patriots is when they rebuild they still
go to afc championship games or go to
the super bowl and just lose that's
what's amazing i mean they were
rebuilding in 2009 and 10 and 11 and 12.
and they were still one of the three or
four best teams in football every year
that's what's amazing and i still think
even this rebuilding process right now
if brady comes back that they're going
to be a handful in the afc no matter
what
i wonder how much brady's decision
ultimately is influenced by whether to
what extent he believes the patriots can
still master the division the way they
used to because that's one of the keys
to getting a buy and now there's only
one buy per conference and that that's
part of the calculus for me and i think
number one the nfc makes more sense than
the afc but then number two is the west
i know the f we we love the idea of him
playing for the 49ers but you guys scary
rams yeah cardinals i still i still
i i hope
i know you want chaos jerry jones that
jerry jones wakes up
carpe diem
and you know dak
he's trying to he's trying to uh carpe
uh
uh diem jerry jones money he's trying to
he's trying to carpe diem the per diem
at some point you say enough
enough
uh and and i think that uh i i i i just
can't i can't imagine it possibly
happening it ain't gonna happen no it's
not tom
you don't listen to mike gloria okay
that's what i want do it jerry do it
roger staubach will let him wear number
12. do it put up the picture do it the
tom brady in the in the number 12 jersey
for the dallas cowboys that would be
awesome but that's the division that i
think he's got the best chance to
dominate the way he's dominated the afc
east for the last decade well that's
fair that's it is i love that that's
fair well there's also an image of him
running out of the tunnel uh in in san
francisco that i know i put on my
instagram uh earlier this week where you
know it's basically jimmy garoppolo but
they changed the zero to a two and put
his face on there so i'm sure that made
jimmy g feel really good there it is
oh gosh
poor jimmy g he's like i can't get away
from this freaking guy what the hell
uh but to your point with the you know
the nfc's which this is not happening
he's not going to dallas but you're
right i mean any great dynasty you
really look at it more times than not
those teams came out of divisions that
you know were not overly competitive at
the time the 49ers the great 49ers teams
of the 80s you know the nfc west at that
time was not considered a juggernaut
meanwhile the teams in the nfc east the
you know the giants the the redskins the
eagles and cowboys were killing each
other you know then the 49ers get to go
in the playoffs fresh and feeling good
why you know their biggest threats have
killed each other all season long so
that is part of it and you're right i
mean that's why i think you the afc west
no way and nfc west is scary too as
great as we thought the 49ers were they
were an inch away from being a five seed
this year and who knows where it goes i
mean or or a non-pass interference call
in the end zone to go oh the seahawks
got the first round bye they've won the
nfc west and now you're on the road in
the wild card game san francisco so that
nfc west to your point is scary as hell
with those coaches and quarterbacks
there
and the saints would have had a buy yeah
and the saints wouldn't have to play the
vikings in the wild card round and the
packers would have been the one seed i
mean that one sequence yes where the and
the season-ending sequence on nbc sunday
night football
and look at what that ultimately
determined now would it have changed who
won the super bowl who knows because the
chief still pulled it off but it just
shows you how close it all is
and if you can be dominant you put
yourself in position to not have to rely
upon a bounce of the ball or an on call
and you just know going in we are the
team and the super bowl uh comes through
us
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports